in January 1959 Ho Chi Minh in the
Central Committee of the Vietnamese
Communist Party the highest political
Authority in North Vietnam gathered for
the 15th party plenum in Hanoi the main
issue on the agenda was the question of
what to do about the continued partition
of Vietnam
promised election and reunification had
not occurred and instead nodes in ZM and
Consolidated his power over South
Vietnam
he was receiving substantial military
and economic aid for the United States
and his regime was doing a distressingly
effective job of harassing suppressing
and destroying the Communist Vietnam
gorillas who had stayed behind in the
hopes of sparking a popular revolution
that would bring the South into the
northern fold
these Southern revolutionaries badly
needed more help from North Vietnam
otherwise they may well cease to exist
so the question the Central Committee
now faced was whether to seriously
commit themselves to unifying the
country by force
this would mean mobilizing their own
population for war and funneling weapons
training money and other assistance to
the insurgents
the Central Committee had to consider
the attitude of the great powers to such
a move
how would the Americans respond
and with the Soviets and Chinese support
their actions
the latter question especially mattered
because the North Vietnamese could not
hope to prosecute any kind of
substantial long-term conflict without
massive aid from at least one and
preferably both of the Communist
superpowers
as the plenum unfolded
the arguments for and against War rage
back and forth
cautious voices raise concerns that
escalating the war would provoke an
American intervention that might
strengthen ZM perhaps even to the point
where he could conquer the North
they also worried that the Soviets and
the Chinese which shrink from supporting
the cause of so-called Liberation for
fear of amping up Global Cold War
tensions
yet a failure to fight partition might
cause DM's regime to become entrenched
similar to South Korea where Singh
monres autocratic U.S backed government
was in no danger of falling
within the central committee and its
inner leadership known as the polypiero
two rival factions had emerged
on the one hand there were the
interventionists or South First faction
who argued that it was the party's
responsibility to take direct action to
keep this kind of thing from happening
they push for an all-out military
struggle to unify Vietnam by force the
most prominent and persuasive
interventionists was lei zwan fiery
party stalwart who had by now logged
many years on the ground in the South
carrying on the struggle
his wealth of practical Real World
experience as an Insurgent leader and is
on compromising personality made him a
formidable figure
ruthless and hard-headed the zealous
lays lawn was not the sort of man to
trifle with
there is no other path for the people of
the South but the path of Revolution he
had once written
opposing the interventionists was the
North First faction we wanted to
prioritize domestic policy in the
economic development of North Vietnam
which have been deeply scarred by a
decade of conflict with the French
they believe that a flourishing
communist state in the north would win
converts in the south
laying the path for a peaceful
reunification by diplomatic means and or
the referendum mandated by the Geneva
accords
for the first few years after partition
the North First faction was the more
powerful of the two
its leader was Chong chin then serving
as General Secretary of the party
now both Ho Chi Minh and vo win Zapp
were counted amongst its supporters
accordingly the focus of the North's
efforts in its first years of formal
Independence was on internal development
foremost was a massive program of land
reform from 1953 to 1956 designed to end
the extreme economic inequality in
periodic famines of the colonial regime
by redistributing Farmland to many of
North Vietnam's poorest and boosting
agricultural production
on one level the program was a great
success
after three years nearly a million
hectares of land were divided amongst
four million peasant farmers
food output increased by nearly 60
percent and the Norse economy had not
only recovered but surpassed its peak
under French rule
it also generated enormous loyalty for
the party amongst the rural poor
yet the program was Hasty and local
authorities were given wide latitude to
denounce prosecute or even execute
landowners in the process
a violent wave of score settling in
class conflict was Unleashed across the
country
with tens of thousands including many
intellectuals business owners and
professionals harassed or killed
faced with such widespread abuses and
outcry from prominent party members in
1956 a tearful Ho Chi Minh admitted the
party had made mistakes in its approach
and apologized
General Secretary Chung chin
subsequently resigned and the reputation
of the North First faction was damaged
its position was further eroded that
year when the deadline said in Geneva
for a reunification referendum came and
went
president's Yem backed by the U.S argued
that the conditions did not exist for
free and fair elections and refused to
hold them
within the Vietnamese Communist Party
Support began to swing behind the
warhawks
by the 1959 meeting liaison in the South
First faction were in the ascendancy
hoe went along with the new pro-war
majority but favored only a limited
Grassroots Guerrilla War
he ordered communist operatives to focus
on building and surgeon organizations at
the Village level and fight only small
battles designed to gradually weaken
zm's government until the day when
International opinion and support might
create favorable conditions for the
north to finish them off and unite
Vietnam
hoe asked the Soviets and the Chinese to
support their southern push
he was disappointed when Nikita
khrushchev's government refused to help
and urged him to give up the idea of
taking over the South by force
by contrast miles odong and the Chinese
fully approved a war and promised to
provide ho with 5 million dollars worth
of weapons and supplies
had the Chinese not done this North
Vietnam might have had difficulty
carrying out even this limited war in
the South and may have caused even
lazulon to think twice about the wisdom
of the strategy
it's important to note that just as
American Support was vital for Saigon so
too Chinese and eventually Soviet
support was every bit as crucial for the
Communist cause
without outside sponsorship neither of
the vietnams could hope to Prevail in a
war
envisioned a gradual long-term conflict
that would lead to victory years in the
future perhaps even after he was gone
he could not know that once unleashed
the forces of War were going to
accelerate Beyond his control
nonetheless the decision to embrace a
violent path to reunification further
empowered the southern first faction
the next year Les Juan became Secretary
General of the party a likely
disappointment for ho who would have
preferred a moderate in the post
now nearly 70 though who could no longer
command the party as he once had
though he remained a beloved figurehead
and continue to influence Northern
policy laso on and his allies were now
firmly in the driver's seat
in December 1960 the Communists
established the National Liberation for
under NLF
a formal political face for the growing
Insurgency they were sponsoring in South
Vietnam
the new organization announced that it
aimed to quote overthrow the disguised
Colonial regime of the imperialists and
the dictatorial administration
and to form a national and Democratic
Coalition Administration
the military arm of the NLF became known
as The Liberation Army of South Vietnam
or lasv presidents yam dubbed them via
Kong or VC term that basically meant
Vietnamese Communists and one that has
remained predominant in his historical
posterity to describe both the political
organization and its Guerrilla forces
the NLF portrayed itself as a broad
Coalition of Vietnamese nationalists
including non-communists who had joined
forces with their communist countrymen
to rid Vietnam of an imperialist puppet
regime
to be sure the NLF for its entire
existence did include many operatives
especially in the countryside who simply
disliked The Saigon government and new
were cared little about communist
ideology
but the reality was that the NLF was a
communist organization
and though led by prominent Southern
Communists the NLF ultimately took its
orders from Hanoi
and it was sustained by weapons and
other supplies covertly filtered to them
from north to south
the composition of the NLF and the way
it attempted to portray itself was
strikingly similar to the Viet man of
earlier years
defining itself as the only legitimate
home for Vietnamese nationalism
but beneath this ursatz veneer
NLF was a front controlled by
uncompromising Communists like liaison
and they had zero tolerance for any
other political opposition
so it cannot be said that this new
Guerrilla opposition of Saigon was
entirely spontaneous and indigenous
nor can it be said though that the
Insurgency in South Vietnam was entirely
or even mostly of North Vietnamese
creation
there was plenty of Grassroots
opposition to the ZM regime especially
in the poor and rural areas from which
the viacon readily attracted recruits
and supporters
in 1954 the U.S pressured ZM to Embark
upon land reforms like the Norse to win
greater rural support and break up the
colonial era plantations
many areas though the Vietnam had
already redistributed land during the
Insurgency against the French
and the South's program is far less
aggressive and less generous
corruption and opportunism ran rampant
with many large Holdings remaining
untouched
and some landlords had amassed more land
rather than less by the end of the
process
in the end the program achieved little
and Stoke further resentment in the
countryside
Hanoi nurtured grew and expanded this
existing opposition through a calculated
and ultimately massive effort to make
war on South Vietnam
to use a simple analogy the North
Vietnamese turned an already existing
brush fire into an enormous
conflagration
NLF operatives began assassinating
Saigon government officials ambushing
government troops and establishing
Shadow governments in rural villages
on the military side there were two
principal kinds of via con gorillas
local force and Main Force
local Force insurgents function as
part-time militia usually in their own
home villages
they focus on recruiting Gathering
intelligence political agitation along
with sniping and ambushes against
government officials and troops
main Force Vietnam were better trained
better armed full-time soldiers who
operated beyond their own homes
as the war expanded main Force
battalions became a formidable military
force capable of taking the fight to
DM's troops and ultimately The Americans
as Viacom attacks and sabotage started
to create serious headaches for GM
fighting also rage in neighboring Laos
between monarchists non-communist
writers and communist guerrillas known
as the path at Lao
the North Vietnamese and the Soviets
were providing Aid to the path at Lao
and the Americans support it at various
times both of the non-communist groups
this proxy war in Laos could well have
led to a direct confrontation between
the superpowers
for a short time the Americans even
contemplated sending in troops
on a 1961 newly inaugurated President
John Kennedy pivoted away from
Intervention in Laos as did Soviet
Premier Nikita Khrushchev
at an International Conference in Geneva
involving 14 countries the Americans and
Soviets brokered a peace settlement that
established a shaky coalition government
in Laos with a kind of power sharing
arrangement
the foreign powers pledge neutrality and
agreed to cease all military involvement
the Laotian settlement had good and bad
points to it
at a time when events in Cuba and Berlin
had seriously ramped up Cold War
tensions the lay ocean settlement
represented a welcome diminution of
hostilities heading off another
potentially dangerous confrontation
between America and the Soviet Union
but it also had ominous future
consequences
the idea that the warring Laotian groups
could set aside their differences in
favor of a coalition-style government
was never realistic
Civil War boiled on unabated and the
path that Lao established a firm hold on
the Eastern regions of the country that
bordered Vietnam
moreover the North Vietnamese never
withdrew their troops
instead they joined forces with the path
at Lao and cultivated increasingly
sophisticated bases and routes to funnel
weapons food and other supplies to the
vietcon
this was the logistical Network that
generally became known as the Ho Chi
Minh trail and a played a pivotal role
in the sustainment of perpetuation of
communist resistance to The Saigon
regime
in response to this the Americans waged
to clandestine CIA LED war of their own
joining forces with local tribes in
hopes of sabotaging communist influence
eventually of course the Americans would
conduct a major air campaign and run
Special Operations raids into Laos as
well
the Laotian settlement may have averted
a wider War but at the terrible price
the seeding a vital sphere of influence
to the North Vietnamese
and one that would plague the American
war effort in Vietnam
in short the Americans never really
solved the Laotian problem and they
would pay a heavy price for this failure
and in the South the Viet Cong were
posing ever more of a threat
insurgents blew up Bridges dug tunnels
assassinated officials and terrorized
villagers
in some regions DM's regime was losing
control entirely
in early 1960 when T din one of the few
female commanders of the war led a mass
Uprising in the impoverished riverine
province of Ben Trey that toppled the
local authorities
by 1961 the VC had taken effective or
partial control over numerous rural
districts particularly along Vietnam's
border with Cambodia and Laos into which
Northern supplies could easily
infiltrate and in the Mekong Delta were
local resistance to The Saigon regime
had already been strong
these areas controlled by the VC would
become critical to the Insurgency
providing Foods supplies intelligence
labor shelter and logistical support to
the Communist forces throughout the war
with the Insurgency growing rapidly in
DM's regime losing its grip it now fell
to President John Kennedy to determine
how the Americans should respond
like his predecessors Eisenhower and
Truman Kennedy believed in the Domino
Theory and it was clear to him that the
conflict in South Vietnam was now both a
Civil War and a cold war contest
the growth of the Viet Cong could not
possibly have happened without North
Vietnamese and Chinese assistance
and if the United States stood by and
allowed ZM to face his threat on aided
containment might be rendered
meaningless and the security of
America's asia-pacific allies such as
Thailand the Philippines South Korea
Taiwan and Japan could be compromised
communist victories in Southeast Asia
might also imperil Malaya and Indonesia
both of which were plagued with
tenacious communist insurgencies
Kennedy's Cold War policy emphasized the
concept of flexible response it was
designed to contain Communism by
reinforcing American advantages and
nuclear weaponry sea power and air power
while also developing viable means of
combating communist uprisings at the
Grassroots level in contested areas like
Vietnam
this meant counter its urgency Warfare
and I called for Americans to immerse
themselves in the culture on the ground
work closely with local military forces
and defeat enemy guerrillas at the
Village level
the Army's newly created special forces
units were especially suited to the
socio military mission
its soldiers were hand-picked volunteers
who survived intensive training for
combat and cultural Savvy that equipped
them to win both firefights and local
hearts and Minds
Kennedy's Instinct then was that America
had to contain the Insurgency in South
Vietnam
if we have to fight in Southeast Asia
let's fight in Vietnam he told Dean Rusk
his secretary of state
if South Vietnam should fall a wave of
Domination by communist China could then
sweep over Southeast Asia
the same time the president was leery of
becoming enmeshed in a protracted war
and he had no wish to send large numbers
of American troops to Vietnam
and he worried the mere Act of sending
them would inevitably lead to persistent
demands for more
it's like taking a drink the effect
wears off and you have to take another
equipped
doubts that Kennedy occasionally
expressed about involvement in Vietnam
would give rise in later decades to
simplistic arguments by some filmmakers
and authors that Kennedy strongly
favored disengagement and had he not
been assassinated in 1963 he would have
steered the United States clear from a
major war
truth was far more complex
he certainly expressed plenty of doubts
about Vietnam
and he worried that a worsening
situation there might imperil his
chances for re-election in 1964.
but his actions indicated a man who had
no intention of abandoning the South
Vietnamese regime
and he exceeded the zm's request to step
up the pace of aid
when Kennedy took office in 1961. there
were about 700 American military
personnel in the country
by the end of 1962 there were about 11
000. and at the time when he was
assassinated in November 1963 that
number had swelled to 16
000.
euphemistically described as advisors
some were Special Forces soldiers who
worked closely with South Vietnamese
militiamen and soldiers at the Village
level and often personally fought
against the VC
most of the advisors though served in a
non-combat capacity as administrators
planners and logisticians to coordinate
the many millions of dollars worth of
usaid and military hardware pouring into
the country
the Kennedy administration created a new
organizational structure called military
assistance command Vietnam or macv and
place General Paul Harkins who had
served as George Patton's Deputy Chief
of Staff during World War II in command
the Americans provided the South
Vietnamese with Transport Aircraft
helicopters and enough resources to
expand the army of the Republic of
Vietnam or Arvin to about 200 000
soldiers
buoyed by the growing American
assistance the DM regime in the early
1960s expanded its counterinsurgent
efforts against the Viet Cong
even though the insurgents were now
receiving more support from Hanoi in
Beijing
it was becoming a mutual escalation
death struggle to decide the future of
Vietnam
in attempt to isolate and destroy the VC
M's government created the agraville
program
mainly centered in the Troublesome
Mekong River delta government officials
uprooted rule Vietnamese from their home
Villages and place them into fortified
compounds surrounded by barbed wire
fences and guards
ostensibly the compounds were designed
to protect people from VC encroachment
but to many bewildered peasants who now
find themselves living away from their
ancestral homes cooped up inside the
compounds forced to commute under
government supervision just to tend
their fields The Saigon government
seemed like much more of a threat to
their Liberty than the VC
plus most of the government officials
are educated urbanites with little
affinity for or connection with rural
people
many of whom they look down upon as
Rubes
the agraville program failed miserably
because essentially it deprived people
of their freedom all in the name of
protecting their freedom and obviously
this made no sense
in 1962 the regime tried a different
tactic with the more extensive and
farther reaching strategic Hamlet
program
the idea had a successful historical
precedent in Malaya in the 1950s where
the British had helped defeat communist
guerrillas by providing the population
with local security and the ZM
government attempted to replicate it
instead of moving peasants into
specially created compounds the
government erected fortified perimeters
around existing Villages and smaller
settlements known as hamlets
now this solved the problem of uprooting
people from their ancestral homes but it
did also force them to labor on the
fortifications with no compensation
creating some resentment
Saigon hoped to create a well-connected
network of formidable fortified hamlets
impervious to Viet Cong influence
insurgents would then be deprived of
their Village hiding places along with
much of their sustenance and support
until in the colorful words of one
Kennedy Administration official they
were reduced to quote hungry marauding
bands of Outlaws devoting all their
energies just to survive
DM set the goal of establishing at least
7 000 strategic hamlets by the end of
1962. this was far too ambitious and
encourage a tendency for the government
to overvalue superficial metrics such as
whether a fence was built or barbed wire
strung to evaluate the security of the
village
corrupt officials sometimes appropriated
program funds for themselves
heavy-handed administrators occasionally
behave with arrogance and stupidity
in Malaya the British strategy had
worked in part because most communist
operatives were of Chinese Heritage and
thus ethnically different and often easy
to distinguish from the rest of the
population
but because of the relative ethnic and
linguistic cohesiveness of the
Vietnamese viacon gorillas remained
difficult to identify and separate from
everyone else
too often they were the every man and
every woman
eventually via Kong local and Main Force
units took to attacking hamlets
challenging the Arvin to defend them
and for obvious reasons the government
had great difficulty building strategic
hamlets and VC dominated areas nowhere
near enough rural villagers felt real
loyalty to Saigon
DM claimed that as of 1963 about 7.3
million people were living under the
protection of the program
but a more objective American study
asserted that only about 18 percent of
hamlets could be considered secure in
any way
and those numbers never really improved
significantly
in the big picture though the Strategic
Hamlet program represented an Innovative
and potentially effective approach to
counterinsurgency it did not fulfill its
purpose of defeating the gorillas at the
Village level
was the Strategic Hamlet program Miss
begotten or a missed opportunity
the bulk of Vietnam War historians fall
into either the Orthodox or the
revisionist school of thought
Orthodox historians argued that the war
was an unwinnable tragic disaster
some of them further contend that it was
immoral and wrong
by contrast revisionist historians
believe that South Vietnam in the United
States were right to oppose communism
and could have won the war if they had
fought it differently
in particular by prioritizing the
pacification of the countryside to
defeat the Communists at the Grassroots
not surprisingly historical viewpoints
about zm's role in these critical years
remain mixed
Orthodox historians have portrayed him
as a dynamic but overly repressive
dictator who presided over an unpopular
regime that had little legitimacy and no
appeal to the average Vietnamese
especially in the countryside
to make the case for his ineffectiveness
they especially point to his
incarceration of political opponents
some of whom were not even Communists
and his persecution of Buddhists
revisionists conceded the point that he
was authoritarian but argued that this
was typical and expected in the context
of Vietnamese politics and at any rate
whatever is depredations they paled in
comparison with the horrifying brutality
of the Communists
in the revisionist view DM had every bit
as much of a legitimate claim to
Vietnamese nationalism as did Ho Chi
Minh in the Communists
he was a personally honest
intellectually brilliant leader who was
totally committed to establishing a
post-colonial independent non-communist
future for his country
and so the argument goes He proved more
effective in combating the Viacom than
Orthodox historians had admitted
in short the revisionist CDM is a true
communist nemesis
a singular leader who could defeat the
Viet Cong and foil North Vietnam's goal
of uniting the country under communism
regardless of how you evaluate ZM
there's no doubt that by 1962 the fury
and intensity of the war in South
Vietnam was growing and his regime now
faced a crisis
the Department of Defense estimated that
at least 10 percent of South Vietnam's
Villages were under VC control
and they exerted influence at another 60
percent
Arvin was stretched to its limit
fighting increasingly desperate battles
against the rapidly growing force of
communist guerrillas
the number of American advisers
continued to increase
even as the Kennedy administration
searched in vain for a clear path to
Victory and stopped short of going in
wholeheartedly
in the north the Communist leadership
three years after making their fateful
decision to unify Vietnam by force was
also facing a quandary
though the VC had made significant
inroads in the countryside their
influence on the key cities and
settlements was minimal and their
gorillas could not match the American
train and supplied Arvin in open battle
despite the ascendancy of the
interventionists heavy debate broke out
whether to further escalate the war in
the South to truly take the fight to ZM
and how much of their limited resources
they could devote to doing so
their divisions reflected a growing
Schism between the Soviet Union and
China
the Soviets urged de-escalation in South
Vietnam and in Cold War tensions as a
whole
the Chinese pressed for a wider conflict
in Southeast Asia and World Revolution
overall
the divisions in Hanoi inevitably
reflected these opposing perspectives
so really both sides in Vietnam were Now
searching for some way to strike a
mortal blow and avoid the catastrophe of
defeat
as we'll see in our next lecture a major
chapter in the tragic history of the
Vietnam War was about to unfold